- Hey, what's up, y'all.
Thank you so much.
- What is good?
- For doing this show, I
really, really appreciate it,
I know it's an awkward
thing, we tried to make it
look like my show, like, and I love that--
- Is that not a real background,
is that like a virtual background?
- No dude, this is my formal
living room and it's gone
and they literally put
a whole setup behind me.
- That looks so cool.
- That's crazy.
- Donald, are you in a closet?
- I am in my closet.
This is where I escape reality.
I escape the wife, I escape the kids
and this is also where we do the podcast.
- It is funny in this
pandemic time to find,
especially we were in a cabin in Montana,
now I'm in LA, but we were
in a cabin in Montana,
it's so small, and there's
like nowhere to go,
and literally would end up in a bathroom.
And I'm like, "This is
weird, this is weird,
"that I'm in a bathroom."
- Kelly, we started recording
the podcast then Donald
needed to find a place
that was good for sound, and
so he started with his closet
and then he realized that his kids
didn't wanna come in there
and his wife would leave him alone
and so now I think his whole family
thinks he makes the podcast like everyday.
(Kelly laughing)
- He's just sitting in
there doing crosswords.
- Absolutely.
- Absolutely, sometimes I doodle.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.